we're back to over-the-board play what
does it mean for you personally to be
playing in person
yeah i haven't played over the board in
over a year maybe two years so it's
really exciting to finally
sit in front of a physical opponent and
yeah look at a physical board
it feels really nice i'm really looking
forward to it i didn't like any of this
online tournament so i'm looking forward
to playing over the board again it's
definitely gonna be
a fun time coming back to over-the-board
chess i think everyone's in the same
boat
it's gonna be a definitely an
interesting experience coming back
looking forward to it
i really enjoy playing over the board
much more than online
it's not that i don't feel um
comfortable playing online i do it's
just over the board it's just different
you see also people's face expressions
you
i'm so glad i don't need to do it on the
computer anymore because you know it's
just
that screen is just killing you so last
year was my first us championship
uh but i didn't feel like the full
experience because it was online it
wasn't over the board so i'm hoping that
this year it can feel
more
real and
i'm just here to do as best as i can so
i think it's gonna feel different we all
got used to playing online but it's not
really the same feeling as playing over
the board i hope you still remember how
to move the real pieces
yeah for me it's like
kind of weirdly hard to concentrate
online uh if it's like a long time
control like i don't know but for me the
board feels like it kind of looks
different as opposed like on a screen
and yeah i'm just glad to be back to
like real over the board chess it feels
amazing and i was really looking forward
to play live and hoping that
this event would be played live
because it's been so long it seems like
it's in like 10 years and not a year and
a half
i
truly don't like playing online because
i cannot film my opponent it's it's all
about just about me right but whenever
you play um over the board it's not only
about you it's all about your opponent
too you feel them
and
you can make some moves
based on how your opponent is feeling
and that moment it's all about
psychology and connection that we have
during the
rounds so i really prefer
over the board i'm happy to be here to
play like real chess on the board so
this is great i'm very happy to be here
and to play chess well we'll see what it
means when i sit down and do it you know
because it's going to be i think
something new you know definitely i mean
after playing for so long just on the
computer um you know we'll see how how i
adjust to the new uh over-the-board
chest
so i did not play last year uh but i
didn't play even the years before when
it was over the board so for me it's a
complete return kind of to the
chessboard and i think
at least if i speak for myself i've been
really kind of thirsty to play chess
again and just to compete and just to
you know bring my ideas to to play so i
look forward to it